Salut, comme vous me l'avez demandé plusieurs fois depuis quelques mois
on est en train de se faire une semaine spéciale micro-expression.
C'est à dire que tous les jours, je prends une micro-expression
et je vous explique comment elle fonctionne,
quels sont les codes, les muscles qui rentrent en marchent
et on est déjà à la sixième micro-expression... à savoir : le mépris.
Si jamais vous avez raté les autres depuis lundi sachez que dans la description,
je vous ai mis un lien vers une playlist qui regroupe les 7 micro-expressions dont on a parlé cette semaine
♪ Générique ♪
Le mépris c'est un petit peu mon préféré parce qu'il est inratable.
C'est la seule micro-expression qui est asymétrique sur le visage,
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas la rater.
Cette micro-expression s'affiche sur un visage quand quelqu'un se sent supérieur à une autre personne,
quand elle se sent plus forte qu'une autre ou quand elle estime
qu'elle est supérieur sur un acte d'une autre personne ou sur la personne en elle même.
Les muscles qui rentrent en jeu sont les lèvres (via le muscle zygomatique), les lèvres qui remontent.
Mais comme c'est asymétrique il y a un seul côté de la lèvre qui va remonter.
Un petit peu comme dans cette vidéo de démonstration:
[Discours de Nicolas Sarkozy]
Là on voit bien que le verbal et le non verbal ne disent pas la même chose.
L'unité d'action n°10, selon le codage de Paul Ekman, se relève en asymétrie, donc la lèvre supérieure.
Ça dure moins d'une demi seconde, comme toutes les micros-expressions.
On peut donc en déduire qu'à ce moment précis,
Nicolas Sarkozy méprise soit le public qui est en train de faire du bruit pendant qu'il parle,
soit la personne dont il parle, donc François Hollande,
soit les personnes qui ont voté pour François Hollande.
C'est une de ces 3 hypothèses.
Et également présent dans les signes du mépris, il y a le menton qui se relève
et la tête qui se redresse vers l'arrière.
On prend une position comme ça, un espèce de léger mouvement de recul.
Jeudi, j'ai eu un commentaire très intéressant qui me demandait
si on pouvait simuler une micro-expression. Alors, oui et non.
Les deux réponses en même temps :
oui dans le sens où si je mets en marche toutes les unités
d'action qui correspondent à une micro-expression précise, alors je serais en train de la simuler.
C'est le cas des comédiens c'est le cas également de Paul Ekman
qui est capable de contrôler tous ses muscles un par un
et donc de les associer pour faire une micro-expression. Il a une maîtrise complète de ses muscles fasciaux.
Ça me permet d'ailleurs de revenir sur la vidéo de jeudi,
avec le sourire vrai et le sourire faux que je vous demandais d'analyser.
En réalité, les deux sourires étaient simulés parce qu'ils étaient fait à la demande.
Mais il y en avait un qui faisait rentrer toutes les unités d'action d'une vraie joie,
et sur l'autre il manquait certaines de ces unités d'actions.
Et si vous repassez la vidéo, celle de jeudi donc, je vous invite vraiment à le faire.
Vous placez votre main sur le bas du visage des personnes,
vous ne regardez que les yeux, vous cachez le bas de l'écran,
et là vous verrez ça va vous sauter au yeux que y'en a un qui a les yeux rieurs et l'autre pas du tout.
C'est pour ça que je ne vous donne pas la réponse directe,
elle sera flagrante quand vous passerez la main devant.
Et non on ne peut pas simuler une micro-expession,
dans le sens ou les signaux apparaissent de manière incontrôlable
durant moins d'1/4 de seconde. Ce n'est pas quelque chose que l'on peut maîtriser
dans une conversation d'envoyer ce  signal aussi rapidement
et de l'effacer aussi rapidement en faisant marcher toutes les bonnes unités d'actions ensemble.
C'est pour ça qu'on peut le simuler, oui, pour donner l'expression complète
durant un laps de temps assez long et réfléchi.
Mais on ne peut pas le simuler, le faire apparaître dans une conversation comme une vraie micro-expression.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo !
Je ne sais même plus à combien on est dans le Mental Vlog.
Je vous rappelle, le défi de base c'est faire une vidéo par jour du 1er janvier au 31 décembre.
Alors ça ne veut pas dire que j’arrêterais les vidéos l'année prochaine,
vous le savez si vous avez regardé la vidéo que j'ai faite pour les 100 000 abonnés.
Demain, on clôture les micro-expressions où je vous parle de la tristesse.
Et la semaine prochaine, on se fait une petite semaine de taré
avec des trucs très intéressants dont par exemple une petite mentalisation de Doc Seven
je crois que ce sera mardi.
Pensez à liker cette vidéo avant de partir et surtout à vous abonner,
ça se passe par ici et par ici.
Et rendez-vous demain à 11h.
Tchao !
♪ générique de fin ♪